luke tom nate jake and the taylors here
with the outdoor boys youtube channel
and today
we're going cold weather camping and
we're gonna show them
how it's done and we're gonna show you
some great tips and tricks too are you
guys excited
all right i have some special guests
with me here today i've got andrew and
his daughters liesel and amelia here
and recently they posted online that
because of watching too many outdoor
voice videos
they had decided to go winter camping
and they froze their butts off is that
right yeah yeah
so today we are gonna go through some
great tips and hacks and then we're
gonna go back and do a winter camping
trip
all right we're gonna go through
andrew's gear and see what we can
improve on
okay so these are the kinder camp 40
degree bags these are
nice nice bags but they're kind of warm
weather we got a marmot zero degree bag
a synthetic got a therm-a-rest base camp
sleeping pad that's a nice mat that's a
nice mat
also a like an air matt air mattress
you guys were pretty cold though right
freezing cold freezing cold you got what
about 27 degrees 20 degrees something
like that exactly
all right now that we've checked out
andrew's gear it's really obvious why
they were so cold
andrew's mountain bag were fine but his
daughter's gear was completely
inadequate and that's because it's
really difficult to find
good cold weather camping gear for small
children so we're gonna try to fix that
by showing andrew some good cold weather
gear for kids that's affordable
okay girls the first thing you guys need
is you need better sleeping bags
so check these out here you go we got
some sleeping bags
why don't you pull those out those are
your sleeping bags
see guys how they are these big bags and
they're not squished
yeah whenever you're not using your
sleeping bag you don't squish it up
otherwise the insulation gets too
squished
up and it doesn't work as well so you
keep your bag fluffier by storing it in
a big bag
and you see down here in the bottom of
the bag this is the stuff sack that you
use when you go camping
and you store it in this good quality
sleeping bags will always come
with two bags the stuff sack and the
storage sack
because this is a mummy bag and because
it's a kid-sized bag there's less
dead space inside the bag their little
bodies have trouble heating up dead
space so smaller bags
equal warmer night's sleep big agnes is
hands down the best kids bag
manufacturer and their little red
is a 15 degree bag and the coldest rated
children's bag on the market
yeah having the hood really makes a
difference when it comes to bag
temperature ratings
some companies are a little bit more
liberal than others
generally speaking this bag will be
comfortable 10 to 20 degrees
higher than whatever the rating says
this rating
is under ideal conditions so somebody
who sleeps really warm
who has the best mat the best tent you
know that sort of thing
so a 40 degree bag really is good for 50
to 60 degree weather
but you can improve the temperature
rating of a bag by taking one bag
and shoving it inside another here's
something else you guys are going to
need
this is the rei kinder camp
self-inflating mattress
okay so it's got two valves this one you
open it up
to inflate it and it self-inflates
and then you open this one to deflate it
and what you'll want to do is just let
those sit
for about a day before you use it and
let it fully inflate
and then when you pack it up it should
re-inflate pretty quick
the biggest mistake rookies make when
winter camping is not
getting a good match the thing with
sleeping bags is that it's not the
insulation that keeps you warm it's the
air that's trapped
inside the insulation that keeps you
warm we call this
the loft it's the amount of puffiness in
the sleeping bag
but when you sit inside a sleeping bag
the part that's
in between you and the ground gets
squished and there's very little air
trapped in between that insulation so
your sleeping bag does not insulate you
against the coldness
in the ground that's what your sleeping
mat is for
the temperature rating of a sleeping mat
is measured by its
r value this is a 4.5 r
value kinder camp sleeping mat anything
about
three or higher is a pretty good winter
camping
mat so 4.5 is pretty solid
for a kid's bag and this will work
really well with the big agnes little
red sleeping bags or any other kid size
sleeping bags
they have this sleeve in the back lisa
sweetie you want to come look at this
now you notice this this is just a hair
long and just fold this over
and then you can just pop it in no that
looks like that's a good fit
the big agonist sleeping bags have this
patented sleeve that you insert the mat
in and it keeps the children from
rolling off the mat in the middle of the
night
yes when it comes to winter camping one
of the few products that doesn't need to
be kid-sized is
the sleeping mat kids can sleep just as
well on an adult size camping mat
and hands down the most comfortable
camping mat on the market for kids or
adults
is the mundo king xl from therm-a-rest
this beast is massive it's thick
it's warm it's comfortable but
if size and weight are an issue the sea
to summit comfort light
is second only to the mundo king for
comfort this thing is deceitfully
comfortable
but you can use this in combination with
a much less comfortable foam mat
to have a really thick warm comfortable
bed in the wintertime
oh yeah i will take that eggshell
inflatable mattress over
two and a half maybe three inches of
foam very comfortable
andrew would you like to try out the
warmest sleeping bag in the world
yeah all right let's do that this is the
feathered friends
snowy owl it's a six foot six
bag all
they say negative 60 and you go i
believe it yeah i believe it
the secret to success is apparent
bringing tons
of these adhesive body warmers they last
12 hours and go a long way to keeping
little kids and adults
warm this is a pack of 40 runs about 20
bucks
winter camping gear can kind of be
expensive and if you don't do a lot of
winter camping it can be hard to justify
the expense
a 40 degree bag can be good enough in 20
degree weather if you just have enough
hand warmers
and buying a box of 20 hand warmers can
be a lot cheaper than buying a new
sleeping bag
do you girls like pink okay
these are some snow suits here when it
comes to winter clothes
one piece snow suits are more heat
efficient and more
cost effective they're cheaper than
buying snow pants in a snow coat
together and they keep the heat in
better and keep snow from getting up the
back of the shirt
make sure you buy the size a little
large so you have room to put layers
underneath
and you want the sleeves long so the
kids fingertips
barely stick out of the end of the
sleeve i've yet to find a good pair of
kids gloves
or kids gloves that will stay on and
stay dry
so i just buy the sleeves extra long and
let the kids go without gloves with
their hands and their sleeves
and that works in all but the most
extreme conditions
you know what these are no these are
balaclavas
they're a hatchet it's a kitty cat hat
see yeah
you lose more heat out of your neck and
head than anywhere else in your body a
balaclava will go further to keep you
warm
than just about any other article of
clothing so if you're taking little kids
buy a ten dollar nine dollar balaclava i
think these little kitty cat ones
cost me 10 bucks
[Music]
are you a panda ninja what do you think
is that cool
is that warm yeah that's super warm
i'll put links in the video description
to all of these products featured here
in the video so you guys can do this at
home
you ladies do you like shoes yeah yeah
this one and you can open this one lots
of people their feet get really cold in
the middle of the night
these little baffin camp booties are
super warm and they'll keep you toasty
when you're in the camp
yeah and you can put them on either foot
they're not left and right these are my
booties
but you see they weigh nothing right if
you ever get your feet cold
you just go in your tent take off your
boots throw those on
wear them into your sleeping bag at
night and you're good that's great
wait but i can see how those make a huge
difference you can get down or synthetic
camp booties
baffin makes these for about forty
dollars or you can get them from western
mountaineering for about a hundred
and they're light they're easy to pack
and they keep your feet
super warm i love them go sit on your
snow suit and open it up
can you show them oh nice
one of the biggest struggles kids have
in the wintertime is keeping their feet
warm kids get cold feet
so easily so here are two great examples
of winter boots at different price
points the absolute gold standard
is the baffin boots baffin makes lots of
different
kids models and kids styles these are a
negative
60 boot and they are absolutely amazing
this is the comic winter boots which
also come in many makes and models and
sizes
and they're comparable to the sorelles
or columbia winter boots as well
these are about forty dollars if there's
one piece of winter gear you're gonna
drop some money on
i'd do it on the boots feel those and
kind of get a vibe with how much
insulation they have oh yeah
try these out oh yeah this is baffin
same company that makes the booties i
can already feel the difference in the
weight they feel just slightly heavier
but
oh the insulation but but it's just
apples and oranges
these are a negative 60 boom they make
men's women's children's
and these are my boots that i wear like
my negative 60 boots are the same thing
just
bigger than the bathrooms as well yeah
almost the same model only company that
makes hardcore
negative degree winter boots for
children and kids feet get so cold
awesome all right we've got the gear
we've talked it up it's time to put it
into practice you guys ready to go
camping
yeah yeah all right let's go camping
nichols boys in my car taylor girls in
that car
oh
we're doing back country camping today
we're gonna build little survival
shelters and sleep in them
and we're gonna find and make our own
fire pits and a little camping area
what we're gonna need you to do is go
get firewood so
look around and try to get dry wood and
make a huge pile of it okay
yeah drop make a pile right there good
job bud
[Music]
make that nice pile there
nathan your nose is so black i don't
know what you got into
it's a little better all right we need
to pick our spot so why don't you grab
your sleeping mat and pull that out real
quick take your mat and find a spot
that's flat
that you want to sleep on and then lay
it down and test it out
just lay that down
yeah that's pretty good you got a spot
this works well nice dry flat not so
lumpy
you look up make sure you're not
underneath a dead tree or something
that's going to fall if there's a wind
storm in the middle of the night
get all your sleeping bags all your mats
lay those out first and then we'll build
the
tent around them
got really in my grill once and tried
did you get underground
basement all day no incredible she
wouldn't daughter or like my
mother
all right would that look good tom all
[Music]
right
[Music]
you almost got it oh you got it
oh daddy now there's two fires then can
i try one
there's another fighter
i'm going mine
[Music]
he put
say take a seat on that is that the
right heist yeah we're gonna have
noodles we're gonna have a special kind
of japanese noodle
[Music]
[Music]
all right we got japanese yakisoba
there we go got a whole bunch of
yakisoba cooked up
okay who wants who wants to try this
i do okay there you go once you test
that
you like that time i got i got cream
that's
nice
use the white fork to put the noodles on
your plate
now tom you guys want to try some
pickled ginger pickled ginger and
pickled
radish to go with it here
it's kind of sweet flavoring mm-hmm
you guys want some sodas yeah all right
let's get the sodas out here
here since we're doing kind of a
japanese theme i thought it'd be fun to
bring a whole bunch of japanese drinks
peach flavored aloe verde juice
we got peach flavored ramen we got
barley tea
yuzu flavored ramen we got lychee
flavored kapiko which is called cowpeas
we have original flavor calpis boccari
sweat
strawberry flavored calpus milk kiss
let's start with aloe juice shall we
okay okay i'm making it for you there's
like the
aloe that you uh they make lotion out of
it
now can we do cotton patties what though
bakari sweet though yeah we can do it
it's kind of like a gatorade yeah i like
it pie petty sweet dough is literally my
favorite
[Music]
is a traditional japanese soft drink
ramune has a glass marble in the top of
the bottle
and you shove the marble down into the
bottle to open it
i love marmalade let's try the mugicha
this is roasted barley tea daddy you
have to wait for me i'm still drinking
mine
i've had it described as the water in an
ashtray that's been left out in the rain
is it herbal tea made from roasted
barley yeah i i drink it all
up it tastes like water yeah
weird it's like you guys liked it good
you want to taste them it tastes
like shall we try lychee flavored calpis
this is made from fermented milk
i don't i don't like it you don't like
it daddy can you give me the one
you don't like lychee flavored fermented
milk who wants more ramen
the yuzu flavored yuzu yuzu it's kind of
um it's kind of like a lemon i try to
yeah yeah and light for a minute it'll
go away
really soon what do you think of the
yuzu flavored ramen day i love it
yeah jake you like that marshmallow
yeah yeah all right guys it's bedtime
come over with me to the tent
[Music]
okay there you go there you go
okay all right guys it's late okay
get down to bed all right let's go to
bed and i'll see you guys in the morning
well guys me and andrew stayed up till
like 2 a.m
chatting and it is way too late so i
have got to hop in bed
and heavens help me when i have to get
up in the morning but i will see you
guys then
i think tommy rolled out of the tent
tommy rolled right out of the tent
uh
well it's in the 20s right now and the
japanese soft drink i left out has got
ice in it
not bad this way so we're going to get
this fire roaring so the kids can warm
up when they get out of their bags
whenever that is
let's see how andrew and the girls did
and good morning
good morning you guys sleep well yeah
were you warm yeah
excellent your dad ain't messing around
you got a little buddy here back in
there
oh yeah
hey jacob you awake yeah
yeah did you sleep warm yeah
good hey nathan you awake
did you sleep warm
did somebody little way out there tent
yeah he's still asleep
always oh this
we're having the breakfast of champions
spam and eggs
oh there we go
okay confession time i love spam and
when i was a teenager i used to keep a
case of spam and a case of squirt
in the trunk of my car and if i want to
go fishing after work i would just sit
there in the river and eat raw spam out
of the can
and chase it with a can of squirt that's
not normal is it a snack in japan
[Applause]
would you like some spam it's kind of
like bacon would you like to try a
little spam amelia
no thank you damn is so good
to do anything hardcore we just camped
in the campsite
yeah oh okay no no well we're packing up
it has been
a great time have you guys all had fun
yeah yeah froze did you stay warmly so
yeah
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see more camping
videos check out our camping adventure
playlist i'll put a link in the video
description
below and hopefully this guys will help
you get out there and have some fun too
thanks for watching i'll see you guys
next saturday morning bye
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching